his newest film serenity hits theaters
on Friday January 25th and he is also
back here on the show but for the first
time as the Minister of Culture of the
University of Texas in a certain way
good to see you Matthew McConaughey the
MOC you are the M from BMOC to MOC and
we want s ro standing room only now what
is this Minister of Culture that you've
been named by yes Minister of Culture in
countries
sort of tend to youth sport and art yes
we have two cultural Heritage's and in
Austin at University of Texas but I need
to protect and development okay one with
UT excellence victories winning two with
the City of Austin curation of great
music make a world-class venue to see
large bands the arenas gonna serve as
both of those I have my eye on the eye
on that from the engineering through the
design through the decor what's the
relationship between the fans and our
basketball teams in the new arena that's
in the new arena that's being built
of course the relationship between there
are teams and the fans what's the
relationship of the visiting team
intimidation factor with our fans oh
these are laying that I'm having a real
fun eye on and studying around the
country what have you learned about the
intimidation factor
well laundry and I have to work within
you know some sort of constraints of
what arena we can build sure obviously
it's ideal for the team to have as
vertical of seating as possible that's
the most intimidating the more vertical
this heating are sure much more
intimidating than full latitude yeah so
we're trying to get as vertical as
possible also where's student section
love it
Cameron where are we do you have to be
on the floor the team has to feel you on
the floor the team needs to feel like
what is keeping them from coming on the
floor and taking me out you know so
there's a call to arms not only to our
fans but in the design and the
ergonomics of how you will will flow
through this arena and how you are
involved in the game
and hopefully that we need it's
basically to develop a and and have
engineering-wise
or a home court advantage so this is
some of the stuff that's on your plate
as you're going about your business just
yeah whatever you're doing it's fun to
do that it is I bet it is and where
where does the Minister of Culture stand
on
Bevo rushing a doll absolutely not just
a bulldog a Georgia Bulldog I mean and
then that that pregame exactly what I've
shown the right over there I mean this
could again I was our handler says it
had nothing to do with the dog what what
do we have he says he was upset and he
didn't you know they were not gonna lose
it it was a coincidence that the dog was
that it looked intentional to me boo
Bevo all I know is it me it's during it
was happened during the Rose Bowl itself
so Ohio State's playing Washington and
we're getting ready for that game we're
getting ready for Texas in Georgia
afterwards and all of a sudden Twitter's
like Dutch lighten up that way I was
standing right and found it you have it
yet so were you were you waving around
up this way well went what the hell was
that
Bevo just got a little uh hello kickin
his step there and went after the
bulldog and that definitely set the tone
right that was a home setter I mean we
came out and ran downhill on on Georgia
the team was very quietly confident you
know those are the kind of games where
and I've been around a lot of UT teams
in college team they don't need a
rah-rah speech before a game like that a
team doesn't sometimes you need a
rah-rah speech when you're playing the
team you supposed to beat by 35 but the
team was quietly confident are very
secure and this team's really grown over
the year and Herman's been great with
time off and going in as an underdog and
I'm happy with what he's building there
as far as a football culture now I know
with last time you were here on the show
Matthew McConaughey around the Rich
Eisen show you it yet to meet him yeah
did not met him yet have you obviously
had Tommy we sure have yeah would you
would you what do you make of him
he's obsessed that's good that's good
it's good he's obsessed he goes in in
the zone and have to watch win I talked
to him and I've noticed there's certain
place and I get it cuz when I go to work
mm-hmm I get obsessed too and I get in
the zone where I need to shut out the
outside world and when he's in his zone
he's back off and go yep he's on it
quarterbacks awesome oh Island you look
great didn't he he's got he's got a ton
of ability obviously no we're focused on
guys like two and Trevor Lawrence of
Clemson I mean that gets obviously most
attention because they played in the
National Champion Kane and Trevor
Lawrence is like six foot six and he's a
beast and two is a different animal also
but this kid he's from he's from dress
mix the Mick Foley school run here is
Westlake is putting out a lot of great
quarter out of Austin yeah Baker
Mayfield went Travis on the other side
of town right and this care have you
spoken to this kid oh yeah okay yeah
when he's look you know his you know his
story with his father he's a kid who had
to mature very quickly beyond his years
early but it doesn't take in the first
10 seconds of meeting him you see that
there's a young man with her with a
Constitution knows who he is understands
his history there's not the history he's
been through as well there's not a
moment that's gonna be really bigger
than him mm-hmm
he's not gonna let a moment become
bigger than himself in it and his
confidence
I mean after the after the the four runs
on the one-yard line
we just ran him we they knew we were
running him right in first down second
down third down fourth down he wins he
comes down on the sidelines and
everyone's he just got in on fourth down
and Georgia just loaded up that zone
knew he was coming in nailed him in he
still got in and he comes up on the
sideline everyone's behind you know rah
rah I mean he's kind of looks over
shoulder
like yes that tar quarterback right
there Texas Longhorn quarterback yes sir
now did you ever have any have you ever
met Mayfield ever had a conversation
with Baker Mayfield knows kind he's kind
of got that sort of rally on him too
that's damn right he does and now the
Cleveland Browns fans are learning and
it seems to be working out for him to
gosh he's planted in a lag like he did
at Ohio State he's planted that flag
right in the middle of the city
Cleveland everybody's following yeah you
got it
I mean you gotta love that confidence
mm-hmm and there's a difference as we
know confidence in braggadocious when
you can go when you can go do it mmm and
also play through mistakes and so go no
I'm not about those mistakes watch this
in the end I will I will have more wins
than losses I will lead us back more
than screw up he's got it and then you
don't you know and they that's why
Cleveland said they they drafted they
said when he walked in a room he was the
quarterback that one goes whoa you know
he's in the room so what is that effect
on the rest of the locker room you can't
measure that nope but it did sure does
have value well you got it when you when
you said I mean look you you know what
it's like you're you're you're you're
won an Oscar you're an actor you know
what it's like to play off of somebody
you know when somebody's got charisma
when they walk in the room you know all
of that stuff it's just there's an it
you got this factor there's an innate
ability and an it factor that you cannot
put a measurement on or an amount on but
it is of high value and you either have
it or you don't and if you don't know
what it is then you probably don't have
it that's right
and it's C I bet Andy Reid felt that
when Patrick mahomes walked in the room
for the first time well he must have
felt that before yeah before drafting
was wow did he go indeed but he wanted
it up they won they moved up in the
first round I remember sitting on the
drafts that we were in Philadelphia on
that draft night and we thought he's
moving up for deshaun Watson and now
came the name Patrick Marber like okay
all right they're talking about great
eyes and you talk about from so far and
you talk about the NFL or college that's
saying ah no no no I'm not talking about
that five star there's a three star over
here that has what I want right and I
want him before that you know that's in
the study and these players whether it's
recruiting or drafting well that's what
you want in your front office is someone
who's seen through
everybody else's measurement or score
and saying no this is exactly what we
need
let me ask you this yes sir how much
does that does the way patch of my homes
is played this year and who the
quarterback you show him to be how much
of that has to do with Cliff cleans very
being in Arizona Arizona I think 99.9
percent and the other infinitesimal
percent is how well Sean McVeigh did as
a young scheming and brilliant offensive
mind I don't know how I've never met
Kingsbury I've met Sean McVeigh he's got
that it factor I mean he hits you over
the head
it's a pungent yet factor when McVeigh
walks in the room
I think everybody's like okay so mahomes
did this in the pros let's get the guy
who had him in college right let's go
get him and it's not an office with
tomatoes no that's a head go the hole
yes the whole shoot man look what
happened in two weeks
mmm fired from Texas Tech yeah fired
from Texas Tech not I'm leavin ya out
get it with the national championship
I'm out of Lubbock going to USC mm-hmm
that was already more than a lateral
move mm-hmm after being fired yep
boom within a week he's Arizona head
coach exactly why I'll check where the
Jets wanted him to for Sam Donald the
USC guy they wanted him to and he went
out Arizona for whatever reason but Josh
Rosen is no slouch they want him to turn
yeah Josh Rosen - what McVeigh's turned
golf into and what Matt neji's turned
true Biscay into Chicago everybody wants
that little piece everyone wants that
taste
Matthew McConaughey here on the Rich
Eisen show who do you like to maybe win
the Superbowl here who do I like to win
the Superbowl I don't know I mean they
did until until Brady proves me wrong
Belichick proved me wrong I'm gonna I'm
gonna roll with me and right I mean how
do you go against in a way a guy that at
age 4 it he uses anything he uses
absolutely anything to motivate and
execute and again there's another guy
who if you ask him he'll run him this is
preparation preparation preparation I
said what Payton did I interviewed Brady
years ago like 18 years ago Mack I want
to fit I won't say I was 20 but how
long's he been playing
20 anyway was early so say 17 years ago
said when you're your best what is it he
goes anticipation because before I've
even taken the snap I've seen the pass I
know it was caught I know if it's a
first down and I'm thinking about the
next play here's I see the future I go
what is it when you win your two worst
he goes we're up by 28 I got an out
route and right before I let go I think
in my mind oh if you're gonna miss it
miss it to the outside not the inside so
you don't get to pick I throw the pick
hmm where's the anticipation he says you
can see it happen before it does and
breezes the same way I imagine yeah and
how about could go back for a second in
that game where they played Philadelphia
mm-hmm I know the question is now what
do we do with Nick Foles is there any
question of what do we do with Carson
Wentz third-round pick I heard you say
for Nick Foles I mean what else did he I
can't even say what else does he have to
do he's done what Nick Foles has done or
is that is that measured as hey that's
postseason if season shine if it goes a
full season we believe the shine wore
off what else does that young man have
to do this a few weeks between now and
when the decision has to be made and one
has to wonder if the decision makers in
Philadelphia at any point in time
take out the MRI of wences knee and the
MRI of whence his back and say what are
we doing here I don't know he's 26 and
he's a great kid 10 like a great human
being on the planet exactly the times 10
years younger than drew Brees
that is correct yeah they're 10 years
apart from Wesley there are 10 years
class of 97 and 2007 yeah they are I
know it's kind of a crazy decision yeah
it is fun all right let's talk about
some of the stuff that's going on in
your world outside of the world of
sports Long Branch whiskey LaBranche
bourbon whiskey in front of those okay
those Russell's at Wild Turkey
Long Branch bourbon what do we have
right here we have Long Branch bourbon
we have mr. Eddie Russell master Siller
signature here and we have first name
that's been on a bottle of Wild Turkey
besides there's Matthew McConaughey so I
wanted to make my own bourbon when I
became creative director creative
director at Wild Turkey hmm
and for two years after whispering and
Eddie Russell's ear about what it was
that I wanted to do he would send me
these tasters little pints then four
pints every few weeks or so well two
years later the 88 pint that I got em
hmm I was having it at a campfire with
my family on my birthday I taste it and
I was like that's it
I didn't say a word and my wife he she
was like that's it and that's what's in
that bottle my favorite bourbon on the
planet okay
do you drink me who's the who's the
who's the person who can handle their
bourbon the best that you've ever been
around Oh
the Russell's are very good at it okay
we get it's almost like an extension and
it's like water how about a colleague
are yours in the acting a colleague of
mine that can handle the Bourbon the
best yes a friend of your show okay
colder couple fingers this is great so
folks can folks can go get this just to
anywhere in American we'll have that to
be all over congratulations on that
ingot and then your foundation just keep
living destination what people can go
right now to JK Living Foundation or yes
now check out what we do if you're if
you're interested there's so many places
to spend your time and money but what we
have going is I'm happy to say
succeeding I'm happy to say what we've
created there's a demand for and we're
seeing true results of of young men and
women getting some assistance they need
in high school these are title one
schools a lot of these kids come from
single-parent homes we're giving them a
place to after school is safe to go
they're setting physical goals that they
they they're setting nutritional goals
we're teaching them how to buy more
nutritional food with the same amount of
money and still go cook at home instead
of buying the fast food food somewhere
we're teaching them about values we're
teaching them life choices so they can
make good choices now because when they
get out they're about to be out of
school and some of those wrong choices
I'm over making the the bites a little
bit more severe if you make that
decision once you're out of school
and we're in shoot we're in like seven
states 40-something schools now that's a
new one doing one we've got a lot of
partners with us to the Redskins a
partner with us the Rangers Cowboys have
helped us out the talking with Baker
actually in Cleveland no kidding yeah
that's amazing does it takes a point
person on the ground there right to help
spearhead our operation we can go plug
in our program but we need somebody with
the enthusiasm there and usually that's
the teacher on the ground or it's
somebody like with the Cavaliers in
Cleveland or someone like a baker who
comes in deck Prescott's helping us out
so that's great and I'm glad the Cowboys
have overlooked the fact that you are
Redskins they had on the stage they've
been they've been they've been very
graceful with me Jerry Jones first
semester you know Marez given he's like
I don't remember what he said but he was
damn graceful about it
probably like saying yeah yeah now you
know with rivals like that I got my guy
who I can write like the Cowboys cuz I
want a [ __ ] fan away I want them to
be undefeated go beat the Cowboys yes as
a Texas University takes a long horn fen
I'm not the long one fan that went to
Oklahoma to lose every game I wanted to
win every game and then I want to beat
them then take care of him yes well it's
a Michigan guy in the same way about
Ohana yeah I know exactly how you feel
and then let's talk serenity here once
again you choose a very interesting role
for yourself right here you play a
fishing boat captain named Baker dill
who is not what it seems
on the outset I don't want to give too
much away I have seen the film there is
a ton there's a there's a ton of Easter
eggs in here that you got to go hunt and
find and and so why did you choose this
role and what do you want folks to know
about this film I'm always looking for
originality
right something unique but also
something that I want to see if I've got
20 films to choose from in front of the
theater what's the first one I want to
go see mm-hmm so that's the scripts I've
been choosing and this is another one of
those this is the kind of movie I
remember angel heart Mickey Rourke at
least we're all in the house he's
playing a detective in his own life
trying to shed if he's real or if the
world he is in is real right this is
similar body heat this didn't feel like
body yay yes that's not like Double
Indemnity yes and and along the way it's
dangerous it's sexy it's fun but it's
it's again you
and I have quite a few way whoa in the
middle of it and then at the end when I
finally get the big answer I kind of you
know it's got a love story of a father
and son running through it as well
doesn't make those those get me all the
time we got you know gets me to those
always make great sports movies too in
this film Noirs well Anne Hathaway plays
your your ex yep and Diane Lane yes film
as well I in Lane she's all kinds of
awesome remember Lori darlin and
Lonesome Dove of course I had a crush on
her since then it was the first thing I
told her when I said you told her
absolutely
what did she said oh she's that she was
she was that's great it's she I think
she was happy to hear it but I was like
I was just yeah I was just transparent
Bob so I was like no I mean I had a big
crush I still did she's wonderful she's
writing everything yeah she's great and
everything in so are you this is a great
movie I've seen it check it out serenity
in theaters on Friday January 25th
thanks for coming on I always appreciate
you stopping by the show always pleasure
is all right check out Long Branch
bourbon just keep living foundation JK
Living Foundation organ again see
serenity with Matthew McConaughey and
you know just keep keep Bevo out of this
is their dogs are now having restraining
orders against people right watch for
you all lightly around Bevo thanks for
coming on my plate Matthew McConaughey
or on the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience